Okay, guys, let's talk about how passive this model really is, and I'm going to be speaking
to those of you that maybe are brand new to this group, like a Kurt Dahlstrom.
Maybe I'm speaking to you that have been in this group for a minute.
You understand the model.
You might even have started building your first project, or maybe you've even landed
your first client, but you haven't really seen how passive this can become.
It's really important, Kurt Thomas, welcome from Cleveland, Ohio, welcome to The Call.
It's very easy for people to toss around the term passive, passive income, passive income,
passive income.
First and foremost, everyone's old enough and mature enough, and hopefully has enough
experience to realize there's really no such thing as 100% passivity, okay?
There's varying degrees of passivity, but there's not passive or non-passive.
It's just degrees, okay?
Even regular real estate is not completely passive.
You got to evict people sometimes.
You got to fix this.
You got to fix that.
You got to raise prices, re-sign contracts.
It's never 100% pass, okay?
Nothing is, and I'm not going to lie to you guys, for those of you that are new, for those
of you that are exploring this model, or for those of you that have gotten into it but
haven't quite gotten that website ranked, I'm not going to lie and say it's completely
passive because nothing is completely passive, okay?
So we're going to start there.
Also, what I would like to do is give away a little bit of swag.
Let me see if I can show everybody, let me see if I can show everybody what we got, okay?
First and foremost, some of the stuff that we have, we have the t-shirts, we have the
mouse pads, we have the AirPod cases, we have the coffee mugs, we have the stickers.
We got a few little knickknacks, whatever, that can sit on your desk.
We got some hoodies, some hats.
So we're going to be giving away some swag today.
So I appreciate you guys being active on the call.
I'm going to be choosing a few winners and give away some stuff, okay?
So just stick with me.
There's Nick Bass, Nick Bassaraba from Canada as well, and we're going to be talking about
a bunch of stuff today, but I'm going to also be doing that, okay?
So for those of you that maybe are new to this group, Kurt, some of you guys have heard
my story, some of you haven't.
I'm not going to share it again, but if you watch any of my content, you'll hear the story.
Been doing this eight years.
I've made by renting, by building and renting simple websites, have made well over a million
dollars for the past four years, with the exception of 2020 and 2021.
Those years, we made a million in 2020, just over.
We did 1.45, 1.5 in 2021, but it's been well over that since, and we will never go back.
But I want you guys to know that we made this money, we're making this money doing the model
that we're teaching in this program, which is building and renting simple websites.
And that's what you need to know about me.
That's what you should be asking yourself is why the heck should I listen to this guy
who's just another, you know, somebody full of crap, whatever, you know, it's crazy how
distrusting I am and how distrusting guys, let me tell you the most hilarious thing that
happened about a month and about five weeks ago, it was just before I went to Dubai.
And my, I have, I have a Lamborghini Huracan parked in my garage.
By the way, I waited until I could pay completely just cash for this thing, or else I wasn't
going to do it.
And this, I bought this thing.
It'd be a year on October 31st, like it's been almost a year guys in 2020.
I've driven it three times.
Okay.
One of those times was about five weeks ago, my son was going to school.
There's only two seats.
You can't even take all the kids, but he's like, yeah, let's take the car, drop me off
in the Lamborghini.
I'm like, okay, cool.
Pull up, drop him off.
His friends are going crazy, whatever.
And I was talking about their school and he goes, yeah, my buddies, my buddies, they asked
me if you rent, if you were renting the Lamborghini.
And I just, I laugh and he didn't even know that was a thing, which is good.
But he's, he told, I said, what'd you say?
He's like, yeah, I just told him, I don't think that's even an option.
The point that I'm making guys is there's so much fake stuff out there that even people
that are even these 10, 11, 12 year old kids, they see a sports car and they just assume
the person's fake.
They assume that they're renting the Lamborghini.
They assume that they're full of crap.
And so you can look at that as a bad thing or a good thing.
I look at it as, as who cares?
I want you guys to be distrusting because if you trust me and just take my word for
it, you're going to trust everybody after me.
So I want you to listen to what I'm saying.
When you get to be in business for a little while, you can tell if somebody's full of
crap or if they've actually been there and done that.
And I want you to like, does, does your gut tell you like, does you feel, does it feel
natural?
Does it feel like I'm making it up?
And if you don't feel like what I'm saying is true, I don't, I don't want you to be on
these calls.
I don't, I don't want you to have to pretend or to fake or whatever.
I want you to question everything and every group you are online and every person that
you hear.
And so I wanted to start by letting you know, I've made millions and millions of dollars
doing the business model of building simple websites and renting them out for passive
income.
That's why I'm here talking to you guys.
Okay.
Not because I think I'm smart.
Not because of this, that or whatever, it's because I've actually done it and I'm continuing
to do it.
Okay.
So what I want to do, my goal by the end of this call, we're going to do like, I'd say
about 20 to 25 minutes.
I'm going to talk about this passivity.
How passive is this model?
And then we're going to go into some Q&A stuff.
Also throughout this call, if you guys have Q&A that's relevant, I want to answer it as
we go.
I know we're not on a zoom call, but I would like this to be more back and forth.
So don't wait until I'm done to ask your questions, ask them, especially if it's related to what
I'm talking about.
Okay.
But again, my goal for this, this episode or it's not really an episode, but this, this
call today is that I want you guys by the end to know exactly how passive this model
is and then you can base your decisions off of that.
Okay.
No BS, no fluff, et cetera.
So here's some of the stuff that we're going to cover, guys.
We're going to be talking about how nothing's truly passive.
Just a tiny bit more.
I've already talked about that.
We're going to talk about where most of the work with this business model comes.
Then we're going to be talking about the most important step of the process.
Then we're going to be talking about different clients and how each client is not created
equally.
Then I'm going to show you guys and talk to you about some of my most passive websites.
Then I'm going to talk to you about why I believe this is the most passive, what, sorry,
why I believe this is such a passive model, why it's, why it can be that passive.
And then I'm going to give you guys a little bit of bonus at the end and we're going to
wrap this up and do some Q&A.
Okay.
So I want to get into it really, really quick, but as usual, I completely forgot to turn
my AC off or on, so give me one second.
It's still like a hundred and freaking something here.
Give me one sec.
Hold on.
All right, guys, let's talk about passive, the passivity of this business model.
Okay.
As I already mentioned, nothing is completely passive.
And by the way, I actually want to ask this question.
If anybody on this call right now, there's 10 of you guys on, if anybody knows of a model
that is completely 100% passive, I would love for you guys to let me know in the comments.
Okay.
Because to my knowledge, there is nothing that is passive, 100%.
Does anyone know of any, any business model out there?
TikTok shop, from TikTok shop to whatever, does anyone know of a business model that
is completely passive?
Matthew Torres, welcome to the call.
I'm going to wait.
Does anybody know of a business model that is completely passive?
John, John Galenvo, I think.
Sean Sean is also in.
Kurt says just failure.
Yeah, that's passive.
Luke Pritchard, what's on, or what's going on, man?
Luke Pritchard was our winner of our recent scholarship.
Shout out to Luke in Australia.
So guys, as I'm continuing, if you guys can think of anything that's 100% passive, please
let me know.
But to my knowledge, there's no such thing.
Okay.
As I mentioned before, there's, there's nothing that's completely passive.
There's varying degrees of passivity.
And on the one hand, there's something, there's things that are not passive at all.
On the other hand, there's things that are very passive.
And we're going to talk about where on the scale this business model actually ends up.
Okay.
For those of you that have never done this, what you need to understand about this business
model is that all of the work of this business model is front loaded and it is very, very
front loaded.
Okay.
It's not like you do a certain amount here and then you do a certain amount in the middle
and then a little bit at the end.
It is almost entirely front loaded and it seems like a lot in the beginning.
But if you can get to the point where you can get the client, get the website ranking,
get the ads turned down a bit, you can create something that is pretty darn passive.
Jason Allred says nothing is passive.
I don't think so either, but if somebody can correct me, that'd be great.
Okay.
Guys.
The reason why this is such a front loaded business is because, I'm going to say this,
the biggest thing which we're going to, I don't want to jump ahead too much, but the
biggest thing that you got to start with is you got to pick the right city and you got
to pick the right industry.
If you don't pick the right city and the right industry, you're dead in the water.
Okay.
I know some of you guys have been in this long enough.
You're like, yeah, we already know this, but I don't know if you actually understand how
important this is.
What happens is when you first get into this model, you're so anxious to get your first
website up.
You're so anxious to just get going, which I respect and I love, but you go and you go
into the wrong city, you go into the wrong niche and then you're like, I can't get my
website to rank or my website's ranking, it's not producing leads or my website's ranking,
it's producing leads, but I can't find a hungry business owner.
Any one of those options does not equal money.
So guys, you have to know how to do due diligence.
You have to know how to pick a city and how to pick a niche.
Some of you guys think that just because you research something and the CPC is below $5,
which for those of you who have no idea what I'm talking about, I'm coming, just chill,
that you're just going to go into it.
That's not the case, guys.
It took me from 2016 to 2020, mid-2020, before I felt like I had a process for picking a
city and a niche, that was bulletproof and the only reason I was able to develop it is
because I went into so many of the wrong cities and so many of the wrong niches.
I went into 50 different cities in the wrong niche, okay, 50.
I don't know how many times I've been into a city and a niche that looked good and I've
come to find out it's not good, okay.
I've made the mistakes, I've done all those things and that's how I know what the model
is.
So you got to, you know, it's front-loaded because you got to pick the city, you got
to pick the niche, you got to make sure that's perfect.
Then you got to also, you know, let's say you got to land the client.
The way that I teach it is I go, I get a client first, I get the contract, I get the credit
contract, you got to get the client.
Then once you get the client, you got to build a website and after you build the website,
you got to do the SEO and the content and da-da-da-da-da and then you got to do the
backlinks, you got to get this ranked, you got to keep the client happy.
But guys, once you get to the point where you've built the website, you got the deal,
okay, and these are not in any specific order because you guys know that I get the client
first and then I get the website.
But once you get to the point where you do those things, you have a website, you have
a client and the client has been with you that initial six months, okay?
What I do at that point is I roll them into another contract.
So they're with me six months and then I'm like, hey, does this sound like, is it going
good because for me it looks good, I would like to continue with you, are you going to
continue with me?
Yes, okay, sounds good.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to extend this out a year and I'm going to lock in your rate for you.
And guys, I'm telling you that if you can just get business owners, keep them happy,
get them to that six month mark and get them into a second contract, even if it's six months,
but I try to get them into a year contract right away.
So then I'm always on yearly contracts, right?
Once you get past that initial contract, if you can get them to sign into another one
and you've done your homework, you've done your SEO, you've done your website, this is
where the business model becomes fun.
This is where the business model becomes very, very passive and this is where everything
opens up and you can start to really scale, okay?
But I'm here to tell you that all the work is going to come in that first six months
and inside of that first six months, 90% of that work is going to come inside the first
month, because that's when you're going to be landing the client, when you're going to
be doing the due diligence, when you're going to be sending the leads, when you're going
to be setting up the website.
And then once you get the website, you start doing the content, then you're just slowly
dripping out backlinks or updating this, that, adding a photo, doing a blog, whatever, and
it's not that much.
So in the first six months is all of the work.
All of the work is in the first six months.
Inside of those six months, inside the first month, maybe even say 45 days to be safe,
inside the first 45 days of the first six months is where all the work comes and it
slowly begins to get lighter and lighter and easier and easier, okay?
So you guys need to understand that this business model is frontloaded, okay?
Now Scott Gray asked the golden question.
He said, how do you pick the city and niche?
Very carefully, my friend, very carefully.
I'm going to give you guys a couple of criteria, but again, guys, that is, there's no way
I could answer that on this call.
Even if we had an hour call dedicated to that question, then there's no way I could even
touch it.
It is something that is an exact process.
That's something that we teach inside Digital Landlords, however, you don't have to be inside
Digital Landlords.
You can go develop your own due diligence.
You can go develop your own system for picking a city and a niche, but it's going to require
you to be willing to fail on a lot of projects, be willing to not rank on a lot of projects.
So a couple of things, though, guys, on the niche.
I'm a big believer, you guys have heard me say this before, go into the boring, tried
and true niches until you get till your bills are paid.
If your bills are 10K a month, you probably need to make about $15,000, $16,000 gross
to net that because you're going to have some ad spend in there if you're going to pre-sell.
So until you get to like $15,000, $16,000 per month gross, I wouldn't even worry about
changing niches.
I would stay in the basic niches, the concrete, the spray foam, the masonry, artificial grass,
the fencing, the, you know, duct cleaning, the gutter installation, the basic tried and
true niches first.
Okay, that's what I'd say in terms of the niches.
Picking a city, I'll give you a couple of tips.
Number one, population does not matter, search volume does, growing areas, if you know that
it's a growing area because you've lived there, you have family there, you have some kind
of intel, maybe you're a lumber salesman and you like know that the top performing reps
are in Bentonville, Arkansas and you're like, oh, that's weird, it must be a huge boom.
That's interesting, you're going to be, there's a lot of population, so that means that most
of the time for these basic services, there's going to be an increase in demand, right,
because the area is growing.
Another thing on city is typically the lower the population, the lower the competition,
but that's not always the case.
What else can I say in terms of city?
I would definitely highly, highly, highly and strongly recommend that whatever city
you go into, that the average cost per click is less than $5 and if that doesn't mean anything
to you, it doesn't make any sense at all, you haven't watched enough content, but it
will, those are some of my criteria, but everyone wants to talk about population and this, that,
the rest, oh, the other thing I would mention, try not to go in cities and states that are
super seasonal, okay?
I try to stay out of North Dakota, I try to stay out of Minnesota, I try to stay out of
stuff that's so extreme, Chicago, it's very hot, it's very cold and it's swinging and
all of a sudden you've got these contractors that don't want to work and all this stuff,
that's just some of the things I would recommend without giving you all the secret sauce, okay?
There you go.
Scott, does that answer your question?
Okay, we've got another question.
Munib Kashif says one question, if there's no ads running in your niche and also there
are businesses ranked organically, is it a flag not to get in there, especially if you're
beginning?
If there's ads in your niche and there's also businesses ranked organically, there's always
going to be businesses ranked organically, dog, somebody's got to be ranked organically,
so that's not a red flag for me, if I see businesses ranked organically, then that's
just part of Google, somebody has to rank at the top of Google, you know, even if it's
crappy competition, they're still taking your traffic, so I don't worry as much about that
and also if people are running ads, no, that doesn't scare me at all.
If people are running ads, you know what that means?
That means that they've got some hungry business owners that I'm going to go sell to, I'm going
to go sell my service to these hungry business owners, so absolutely not, is that a red flag
in my opinion, okay?
Good question.
If anyone has any more questions, keep dropping the questions, these are good questions, they're
relevant questions, I appreciate them, okay?
Next thing I want to talk about really, really quick, guys, is just to reiterate a little
bit more, is if you pick the right city and you pick the right niche, once you are ranked,
this business requires very little work, it's kind of like climbing a mountain, okay?
And what I mean by that, if you guys have ever climbed a mountain, it's like this huge
steep ascension and you get, you're climbing, you're grabbing branches, you're falling down,
you're getting dirty, whatever, whatever, you just claw your way to the top and it's
a real pain, and then once you get to the top, to stay at the top is very easy, right?
A lot of times these hills, they're flat at the top, whatever, once you get to the top,
to stay at the top, it's easy, it's very, very easy, right?
It's the climb that's so hard, and so you guys need to understand that even though you've
got all this front-load of work, you've got six months of hard work and probably 45 days
of really hard work in the very beginning, guys, once you get to the top of this mountain,
once you get to that six-month mark, websites ranking, clients in the year two or the second
contract, this business model becomes very, very passive, okay?
And I've got plenty of different examples for you guys that I can share, but I just
want you guys to understand that you've got to remember that picking that right city in
that right niche is so vital because it changes the entire freaking game, and if you don't
pick the right city in the right niche, from experience, everything becomes harder, okay?
Now let's talk really quick.
I want to let you guys know that not all clients are created equally, okay?
Not all clients, and the truth is that once you get to the top of Google, you're pretty
well going to stay ranked at the top of Google.
Unless somebody comes in, it's like a really popular city, it's a big city, and you attract
some big competition, most likely you're not going to get overtaken, and even if you do,
you're going to get bumped down one spot, you do a little bit of SEO, you're back up,
okay?
It's not going to be that difficult once you get ranked to stay at the top.
However, okay, however, business owners are a different story, yeah?
Business owners are a different story.
You could be at the top of Google, you could be producing the most amount of leads, and
you could have the most high-maintenance business owner on the planet, and that is going to
make this one of the most least passive business models on the planet because of your business
owner, okay?
I've had some of the best business owners that I don't talk to ever, that I literally
talk to once every two years, once every three years, and I'm checking on them to see how
their wife did when they went to surgery.
You could also have the business owner that literally thinks that they can text you every
single day and ask you where the leads are if things are slow for one day.
So you guys need to understand, you hear a lot of these older veterans that are in my
program that have been here a while, and they always talk about picking the right business
owner, picking the right business owner.
And a lot of you guys that are brand new, you're so desperate for money, you're going
to go get the first business owner that offers you money, even if they suck, and it's going
to come and bite you in the butt, okay?
And it's going to bite you in the butt because you're going to be dealing with that person
when you could have been dealing with someone that's way less maintenance for the exact
same price, okay?
Also just so you guys know, you've probably seen these memes, you've probably seen these
things or you might have heard of it, maybe you don't believe it, maybe you do, but I
promise you guys the cheaper, the cheapest clients that you have that are paying you
the least amount of money are always the hardest ones to deal with.
I don't know why it is, I don't know what it is, but that is the truth.
The business owners that are the hardest to deal with are the business owners that pay
the least.
And I don't know why that correlation is, but I think it's because that small amount
of money means everything to them.
And when you deal with the big companies, when you deal with the successful companies,
they don't care because they're willing to test the file, okay?
So just understand that not all clients are created equally and the degree of passivity
your website is going to have is going to largely depend on the client that you're working
with, okay?
Because that client, if you set expectations from the beginning and the client's low maintenance,
the client's chill, you just have to worry about ranking your website.
Once you rank the website, you're going to be glued to the top for the most part.
And if you have a website glued to the top and a very low maintenance client, you have
a freaking, just a gold, a piece of gold sitting in your lap, okay?
It's the best thing ever.
You have a low maintenance client and you have a website that's ranking.
It's the best business model in the world.
If you have a high maintenance client, oh man, or you didn't do your due diligence properly
and you're just doing SEO backlinks, blah, blah, blah, blah, guys, those become very,
very, very challenging.
Okay.
We have a couple of questions here.
Scott says, how about competition in the search results?
Which lead gen in the top 10, do you try another?
That's such a good question.
I've answered this question a few times.
No, I do not run away if that's what you're asking.
If I see another lead generator in the top 10.
And guys, first and foremost, if you guys are looking at competition, which you better
be looking at competition, because if you don't look at who's ranking for the terms
you want to rank for, you have no idea who you're going against.
If you have no idea who you're going against, you don't know how well you need to prepare,
how dialed in you need to be.
So my first tip for you guys is if you're looking at competition, make sure that you're
using five to seven keywords.
Okay.
Don't just go and type in.
Let me see where somebody was living, hold on.
Let's see.
By the way, Luke just asked a question.
He's about to hop out of the car.
Luke, go ahead and ask that question inside the digital landlords so that we can answer
it there since you're going to hop off because I got two more questions that are coming before
you.
Okay.
So ask that.
Great to have you on the stream.
And looks like he's headed to work.
It is what it is.
Okay.
I got to turn this air off again.
Hold on.
Dude, I got the laziest AC unit in the entire country.
It's 75 degrees upstairs here in my office and it's October.
Now, granted, I know it's hot outside, but my goodness, the AC just doesn't want to crank.
Maybe we should use my house as a lead.
Too bad that's not my favorite niche.
Okay.
Hold on one sec.
Let's see what we got here.
So going back to Scott.
So what I was about to say, guys, is that you need to make sure you're using multiple keywords.
Imagine if I used somebody said they were in Cleveland, Ohio, Kurt Thomas.
Then I go into Cleveland and I type in tree service, Cleveland, Ohio, and I look at it
and it looks super competitive, right?
Because it is.
And everyone there is pretty, you know, these websites are juicy websites, lots of content,
old websites, older domains.
You know, I've got a good backlink profile, good, well-written content.
And I look at the term tree service, Cleveland, Ohio or concrete, what'd I say?
Tree.
I can't remember.
We'll use tree service.
And it looks super competitive.
And I'm like, yeah, I'm out.
Dude, this looks way competitive.
However, what if I went in and I looked at instead of one term, I looked at seven terms
and that term tree service was the most, there was very, very competitive, but tree removal,
tree company, tree cutting, tree service company, tree company near me, tree service company
near me, on and on, tree, tree lopping, whatever, if you're in Australia, all of those terms
are wide open.
There's not much competition, right?
That would mean that I've missed out on a huge opportunity.
On the flip side, I've done this before as I go and I look at one term, I look at foundation
repair Savannah, Georgia.
And dude, that term right there looks amazing.
It looks like it's wide open.
It looks like I can go in, I can rank it.
And I'm like, dude, this is a great opportunity.
The CPC on that one term is good.
I go in and I decide to build a project.
I decide to start running ads, but I forgot to look at the other six keywords, the other
five keywords, and I don't even realize it.
And I get in and I'm getting my butt handed to me because I didn't look at all the keywords.
So the answer, the short answer to your question, Scott, is no, I do not care if I see another
lead generator in there.
All I do is I view that as another competition, as another business owner that's stealing
my leads.
And I got to get in there and steal them back.
That's it.
Okay.
Whether it's a lead generator, whether it's home advisor, whether it's the local concrete
tree service guy, they are stealing your spots.
They are taking your leads and they are competition.
But I'm not going to treat a lead generator as any different of competition than just
Joe down the street.
I just need to look at his website.
If his website is very juicy, very highly ranked, high domain authority, high, really
good backlink profile, I might not go into that.
But if it's garbage, then I'm going to pretend I don't even know that's a lead generation
website and I'm going to go into it anyway.
Okay.
Good comments.
Lars Shepard says, do you have any red flags you look for when you first talk to a B.O.?
Yes.
Number one red flag is they're rude to their clients.
Okay.
This is why I like to live transfer my first few leads, guys.
By the way, we're going to be talking about some of my most passive websites here in just
a second.
Then we're going to get into Q&A.
But if I hear them talking poorly to their clients, don't have good customer service,
you know what I can automatically assume
is that they're not going to retain clients.
And they're probably not gonna close deals.
And if they don't close deals and they don't make money
and they don't retain clients,
they're not gonna be with me very long.
They're not gonna have money.
It's not gonna be an ROI.
Even if my leads are good, there's gonna be no ROI
and I'm going to lose that client.
So if I hear you talking to a client poorly,
if I hear you being rude or short
or non-personal with a client,
I already can tell you
that even though they're willing to give me money,
I'm not gonna take it.
Because I'm looking to build relationships
with business owners that want to be with me
for 10, 15, 20 years and make millions of dollars together.
I'm not looking to get a client today,
three months later, switch it out for somebody else.
So if I hear them talking poorly,
that's a huge red flag for me.
Let's see, I'm in the car on the way to work
so I need to balance my interest to know
once you have finally ranked organically,
are you still drip feeding the sites
with backlinks to content or is it okay?
So he's asking guys, once you rank the site organically,
do you keep dripping on backlinks, keep adding content?
And the answer is you can.
What I've done is I've done such strong due diligence
on most of my websites that I do not even worry about it.
I don't even log into my website.
It's kind of like, if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
We have websites, we don't even,
I mean, we could find the password,
but we don't know the password.
It's not even part of our regular account.
We've got Towing St. George, my last towing project.
I'm never gonna do it again.
We don't touch it.
We've got Bentonville Concrete.
No way I'm touching that.
We've got a handful, 10, 15 sites
that are ranking super well,
and there's absolutely no reason for us to go in
and mess with it because we're already ranking.
So that's the approach that I've chosen to take,
but it's up to you guys.
Okay?
Kurt says good stuff.
So guys, here's what I'm gonna do.
Let me see if I can pull up a couple of websites.
Let me see if I can pull up a couple of websites
for you guys.
Here, show you some of my most passive websites.
And we're gonna do, which ones did I wanna do?
We got that one.
All right.
One more, one more.
Let's see which last one we're gonna do.
There it is.
I'm gonna show you guys my screen here, by the way.
Let me get rid of about 100 things here.
All my Slack messages, all my rain music from nighttime.
Do not connect the phone.
Thank you.
All right, guys, here we go.
Let me show you a couple of my most passive websites
on the interwebs today,
and I should tell you guys exactly how passive they are.
Okay, share my screen.
Boom, boom, boom.
Okay, I don't know if you guys can actually see this,
but I'm gonna start off with Bentonville Concrete.
If you guys have heard me talk about this,
kick it out of my face.
So this is us right here, Bentonville Concrete.
We're in the maps.
This is also us, rank number one.
You can also type in Concrete Contractor Bentonville AR.
Rank number two here, rank number one here, okay?
This is my website.
Guys, I'm going to let you know,
the last time I messaged this person
was on about business,
because once in a while we'll talk about random stuff.
Like he just randomly sent me something a couple weeks ago
about some completely random thing.
But the last time he asked about business, guys,
was on November 10th,
Friday, November 10th of last year.
He said, hey brother,
I've sent a bunch of emails back and forth.
I'd like to get together and talk and figure out
how I can really expand this business.
I know you guys are good at what you do.
And so are we, I want your help.
Let's figure out how we can do this together.
So the only reason this guy even texts me
is because he was asking me for more business, okay?
This is one of my most passive websites.
It's glued to the top.
We haven't logged into this thing in years.
Haven't changed it in years.
I haven't talked to my business owner since November.
There you have it.
And even then I never even got on a call with him, not yet.
Okay, that's my first one.
My second one is one called St. George Epoxy.
If you type in St. George Epoxy, Epoxy St. George,
it's all called stgeorgeepoxy.com.
Check out this beaut.
This guy right here is an absolute,
just pile of you know what, super basic whatever,
but it works.
And I'm gonna look up the business owner
so I can show you guys, or tell you guys at least.
The last time I got a text from him,
I have three unread messages from him.
March 15th, two messages on March 15th,
and a message on March 16th.
The last thing he said is,
we still need to do your pool deck, LOL, okay?
Homie's still trying to scrape my business, no problem.
Come and give me a quote on it.
I don't really mind, okay?
This website right here,
we also have not logged into in years.
We talked to the business owner.
What did I say the date was?
July, it's been over a year.
That's 2023, it's been a year.
July, August, September, been a year and two months.
Haven't talked to the client, okay?
Let's give you guys one more.
We'll do St. George Concrete, type this in.
You're gonna see us, we are running ads.
She's sponsored here, us.
We're ranked number one underneath the map,
or sorry, the paid.
This is it.
Okay?
I'm sorry, this is, okay, here's a perfect example.
This is not my website.
I'm lying to you.
I think it was Scott who was asking.
So look at this, guys, okay?
We got, this should give you guys
so much freaking excitement.
So we got ConcreteStGeorge.com,
which has been there for a long time, okay?
They're actually outranking me.
I'm StGeorgeConcreteCO.com, okay?
That site looked a little too nice for it to be mine, okay?
This is my site in all of its glory, it's a beaut.
And this website makes me $375 per week.
This client, let me just go ahead and check.
What the hell is his name?
Oh, this is gonna be a problem.
Is it, shit.
What is his, ah, yes, I just remembered it.
That's what it is.
Yep, okay, November 18th, 2022.
I got one text from November 18th, 2022.
These guys have spent with me.
Let me look.
What the hell?
Okay, not that, not that, not that, not that.
Okay, not that, not that, not that, right there.
Ah, no, that's, is that it?
No, that's not it, dude.
Okay, oh, right there, there it is.
Okay, this client pays me $375 a week,
has paid me, to date,
five, five, oh, sorry, $57,000 on the nose.
Okay, been with me since November 3rd, 2021,
the website you're looking at.
Not ranked number one, not ranking in the maps,
don't even think I have a maps listing.
This thing is churning out leads, $375 a week.
Unfrickin' believable.
This is some of my most passive websites,
and I just grabbed those ones for fun, okay?
Just to give you guys a bit of an idea,
and guys, here's why I think this model is so passive.
I think this model's really passive
because it's such a binary transaction.
I give you leads, you give me money.
You give me money, I give you leads.
If you stop giving me leads, I stop giving you money.
If I stop giving you money, you stop giving me leads.
Done, done, done.
There's no reporting, there's no this,
can you do this stuff, yes?
Do you have to, no.
Okay, no other business model I know
that's such a cut and dry transaction
that's you do this, and I do this,
or else we're done because the arrangement,
there's no room for fluff, right?
When you're doing SEO,
you could do almost nothing for the client.
It took you no time.
Or you could go hire somebody in the Philippines
to do backlinks, do 100 backlinks,
and you come to the business owner and go,
dude, look, I did 100 backlinks for your website,
and by the way, blah, blah, blah,
it doesn't even make sense,
but you're able to show them and craft it
to make it look like you want it to look.
The downside is, with this business model,
you can't fake it, man, and I think that's an upside,
but you can't fake it.
You can't fake work you didn't do
because if leads don't come in,
leads don't come in and they're paying for leads.
That's why I think this business model is so passive.
It's very cut and dry.
It's leads for dollars, okay?
And then lastly, guys, I just wanna let you guys know
that just because you don't have to talk to your clients,
just because you don't have to call them every five minutes,
because you don't have to send them a report,
I want you to picture a business that you have
that you actually do that,
that you actually treat them like they're your last client.
You treat them like they're all of their money
pays all of your bills and then some
because they're that big of a client
and they're all you have to worry about.
Imagine what your business would be like.
Imagine how excited they would be.
Imagine how they would grow with you.
Imagine how many people they would refer you to.
If you just made the decision,
hey, I'm not required to really follow up with this person
or treat them a certain way,
but I'm gonna do it because that's how I do business.
Imagine how many referrals you'd have
be coming down the freaking pipe, a lot, okay?
A lot.
Guys, this model is one of if not the most passive models
on the internet, no questions asked.
And this is the reason I'm able to travel to Dubai
for a month at a time, two times.
We've been in Africa for three months,
been to London twice,
been to a couple of different places in the US,
including Tuscaloosa, Georgia, Alabama game,
getting ready to potentially go to Arkansas
in a week and a half.
Or if not, I might go back to Africa
during that same time.
All of this is possible because this model is passive
and there's different levels.
Okay, just because you have an online business, that's great.
But if that online business is not passive,
you could travel anywhere you want,
but you're gonna be stuck at the hotel
making sure that business is as usual
or you can't keep living that way.
With this, you can do it, you front load all the work
and then you set it and you forget it, okay?
So guys, that is what I truly believe.
This is how passive these things are.
I will tell you that that website I showed you,
Bentonville Concrete, I don't think we're running any ads.
We have a 20 something dollar a year GoDaddy bill.
Cool, we're paying for a tracking number five bucks
and the domain, sorry, the hosting and the domain.
I think that the domain is the thing that's 24 bucks
and then we have the hosting that's like 13 bucks a month.
So guys, all in on less than $50 per month on a website
that's making me about 900 bucks a month.
That's the case for all of these websites.
That's how low cost these things can actually be, okay?
So that said guys, let's see if we have any questions.
If we do, great.
If we don't, then we will go back to making money.
Let me just pull this up really quick.
Give me a sec, where you at?
Dog, oh, he's just hiding from me.
Okay.
Ah, where is this at?
And by the way guys,
I really appreciate you guys being on the call.
I know you guys got a lot of places you can be.
I know there's a lot of things you could be doing.
There's a lot of places you could spend your time
and I appreciate you doing it here inside of this group.
I really do.
Okay, so let's see what else we've got going on.
Oh, all right, let's go like this.
How important is it to occupy more real estate
multiple websites on the first page
for our keywords to hold a monopoly?
I don't have any websites
that have more than one piece of real estate.
I've had websites in the past that I ranked the homepage,
I ranked the service page, we had like two,
plus we had the maps.
But guys, most of my deals
are ranking a website organically.
I don't mess with GMB at all really anymore.
I have some paid ads coming in,
I got some organic coming in,
I keep the client happy with that.
Okay.
Kirk says, how important is GMB and how do you acquire it?
No, it's not, I don't do it anymore.
Guys, in 2020, when I scaled up to $100,000
a month in eight months,
half of my websites didn't even have GMB.
We think that they have to have GMB
because we think somehow the clients know about GMB.
The clients don't know shit, dude.
I'm sorry for the language, but they don't know anything.
So don't think that just because you don't have a GMB,
you're not gonna be able to charge $1,500 a month.
Okay, that concrete website I showed you guys,
let me see if I can even try to find, hold on.
Let me see if I can share the screen really quick.
All right, let's see if we can even find,
I don't even think we have a map listing, dude.
This is $1,500 a month deal
that's paid me over $57,000 so far.
And I'm telling you right now,
we do not have a St. George concrete site.
I think we did, I think it got pulled.
So to answer your question,
I don't worry about it at all, okay?
Laura says, do you feel like Flat Fever's commission
is really important to make this pass?
Yes.
No questions asked.
I can't even imagine doing passive income for one deal,
or sorry, passive.
Commission deals for one deal,
much less a bunch of deals.
That sounds like a nightmare.
That sounds like I'd rather pull out my teeth,
pull out my toenails,
do something like that,
rather than put a rat on top of my head
with a woven basket and let it eat down in my skull,
than doing commission, guys.
Commission does not scale.
They have nothing in the game.
They have no reason to go to these leads.
They have no reason to be better than average.
And most of these guys are very, very average or less, okay?
You have to do flat fee if you want to scale.
If you don't want to scale,
you just want a couple bucks coming in here and there.
You can go to everybody to say yes to a commission deal,
but just know upfront that commission deals don't work.
They don't work long-term.
They don't scale and it is very, very cumbersome.
So that said, if you don't want to believe me,
then go try it.
Kurt says, RIP GMB.
Yeah, RIP GMB, RIP GMB, but you know what?
It is what it is, man.
We're going to move on to the next thing.
That's what we're going to do.
Okay, guys, I appreciate you jumping on this call.
I'm excited to be back.
I think next week we're going to resume
doing the calls Monday at 6.30 a.m.
So we'll keep an eye out for that post.
It tells you exactly what we're going to be talking about.
And we will send you the link.
Real quick though,
I want to give away a couple of pieces of swag.
I want to give Laura Shepard a piece of swag.
Go ahead and message Aaron and say swag winner.
So he knows he'll send you a coupon code.
I also want to give something to Scott.
Scott Gray, I want you to go
and message swag winner to Aaron.
You guys go ahead and get something from the store
completely on the house.
So you go ahead and enjoy that
and then take a picture and let me see it.
I would love that, okay?
Muneb says, thanks man, really informative.
Absolutely guys, appreciate you guys jumping on the call.
If you have anything else going forward,
we will answer it on the next calls.
And with that said guys,
just remember, I like to say this every time,
money loves speed and I am out.
Talk soon.